يعود السيناريو هنا مجددا في ولايه جنوب
دارفور الواقعه غربيه السودان دمار قتل
وتشريد وقرى محترقه بالكامل لتعلن سلطات
حاله الطوارئ مع حظر للتجوال عقب اعمال
عنف قبلي راح ضحيتها عده اشخاص اندلعت
الاشتباكات تلك التي لم تعرف اسبابها حتى
الان بين قبائل العربيه من الرعاه واخرى
افريقيه فيما دفعت الحكومه المحليه بقوات
مشتركه للفصل بين الاطراف المتسارعه كما
لجات الى الاستعانه بالزعماء القبائل
والادارات الاهليه للتدخل والتهدئه
الاوضاع وكونت الحكومه وفقا لبند
الترتيبات الامنيه في اتفاق الجبال للسلام
الموقعي مع الفصائل المسلحه في دافور قوات
المشتركه من جميع الاطراف لحمايه المدنيين
ومنع وقوعه اعمال العنف والاغتال القبلي
خلال العام الحالي شهد العديد من ولايه
دارفور اغتال قبليا واشتباكات مسلحه راحه
ضحيتها مئات المواطنين والاف النازحين
واللاجئين
من زنجبيل مسلحين بجماله
وحجمونا في الهند وحرقوا كل ممتلكاتنا في
الحله
[موسيقى]
بين الحين والاخر صراع الارض والموارد
ومسارات الراعي صراع يرجع صوت البندقيه
ويعيد اله الحرب للدوران فيما يبدو ان
الصراع القبليه التاريخيه هنا لا نهايه له
عصام عبد السلام العربيه